interesting because we see that also
with the like the plants and herbs and
spices that i mentioned with their
built-in plant defense mechanisms or
some of these centenarians who are
smoking like a cigarette a day
or or the the exposure to the radiation
from sunlight or the stress of heat or
cold like i was talking about it's kind
of like this concept of what's called
hormesis things that would be bad for
you in large amounts like alcohol which
is technically a toxin are actually good
for you in small amounts because like
exercise they beat up the body but the
body in the process of bouncing back
becomes stronger it builds more
antioxidants the cells become stronger
and so it's not an idea of living super
clean you know by living super clean you
can actually become a little bit more
weak it's about exposing your body these
mild stressors
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
human performance consultant a speaker
and a new york times best-selling author
of 17 yeah 17 books including beyond
training boundless and fit soul ben
greenfield welcome to the reuben report
hey what's going on man ben this is the
first time for me i have never had a
guest i've probably interviewed about a
thousand people at this point i don't
think i've ever had a guest uh just sort
of wandering in the forest first time
really have you ever had a guest
wandering in the forest naked
are you bare ass naked
well you know in this area you never
know when somebody's wearing pants but
yeah considering that i'm walking
through the neighborhood and not
strolling on the treadmill in my office
i did have to pull on a little bit of
clothing
but uh i'll
i'll try not to uh to have any wardrobe
malfunctions during our
during our show here fair enough i just
like to get like to get my vitamin d you
know yeah yeah this is youtube not
pornhub let's keep it clean um all right
so as you know right now i am
off the grid completely we are taping
this at the end of july for an august
release release i am completely
away from cell phones
all tech television news the whole thing
i'm working on diet i'm working on
exercise and i'm working on a digital
detox uh let's start there with the
digital detox situation as a guy that's
doing uh youtube interviews while doing
exercise and wandering around i take it
uh you think maybe we're a little too
connected these
days well first of all i don't know how
the heck you're staying fit during a
digital detox without being able to be
motivated by all the instagram
influencers out there because we all
know the best way to get fit is via
osmosis and scrolling through uh through
babe and hulk feeds on instagram but
right
that being said yeah i um
you know i i
i i honestly like you know i i really
took a great deal of pride for years and
being like one of those hyper-connected
guys and by hyper connected i don't mean
on social media all day but i mean you
know using all the wearables the self
quantification devices the super
computers on my bike the power meters on
my laces for running you know the the
swimming goggles that tell you how many
laps you swum you know with like a
screen right there in the goggle and
um
and
you know i i really like to be a little
bit more unplugged now i'm pretty bare
bones when it comes to fitness i wear
like a ring that tracks my step count my
sleep and a cheap ass 15 timex you know
and that's that's about all that i do
now
but
you know i think even more related to
your point
is this idea that
you know the the more
connected you are
the more difficult it can be
to to move and to exercise because
you know it's just difficult to engage
on something like social media while
you're working out you know which is
obviously why half the people at a gym
have their asses parked on a bench
hunched over looking on their phones
rather than you know but before that it
was all it was magazines on the tv you
know now it's just replaced by by phones
but you know i um
i think that that there there can be
some efficacy to this stuff like i've
even seen during kovid i mean some of
these companies because i do some
investing in the health and fitness
sector as well and i've seen the
valuation of some of these like home
fitness companies you know the peloton s
companies like tonal and mirror and
catalyst and fight club um and of course
peloton as well just explode and
obviously you need to be connected
to use those type of products during
your session some of them allow for like
offline downloading of the workouts
which i actually encourage people to do
if they can because it's one less
distraction one less notification going
off on your device while you're working
out etc and possibly you know even a
bigger thing here that a lot of people
don't think about
is
all of these devices you know all these
things you need to be connected to they
do emit low-level radiation that could
be problematic in terms of your
mitochondrial function your red blood
cell what's called red blood cell
stickiness or the propensity of red
blood cells to aggregate together the uh
the calcium influx into a cell which
causes a little bit more of a burn and a
slower ability to be able to buffer
lactic acid and some of the things that
build up during lactic acid or during
exercise a lot of that stuff actually
becomes affected by exposure to
um you know uh
your cell phone signal 5g wi-fi etc
that's why a lot of people during a day
of work you know they get brain fog they
feel kind of blah in the afternoon they
don't sleep well they got a bunch of
devices next to their bed and so i
question you know the impact some of
those things are having on you while
you're exercising as well if you are
using those type of things during
exercise and then of course the use
apart from exercise is just
it can be a time suck but there's you
know there's some efficacy i'm not i i
see a ton of benefit in social media for
spreading a lot of good knowledge and
information obviously it can spread
disinformation
negativity as well but you know i think
when responsibly used it's a big
blessing yeah you mentioned uh tonal and
mirror and i just was at the mall the
other day i saw a tunnel so it's
basically like these mirror type i mean
they're literally mirrors that you stand
in front of to work out they have some
uh you know some things you can pull on
and yeah you know they're connected to
the internet and all that do you think
uh there's a risk in people actually
doing this stuff all from home and not
going to the gym not being around other
people getting that kind of motivation
uh
well
first um not not really because they
they enable people to be able to
actually just lower the barrier of entry
right if you can roll out of bed and
walk over to your whatever your basement
or your your backyard or whatever and
just use a home training device and
furthermore relate to the safety
component use a home training device
that now has the ability to have a
personal trainer you know or an expert
walking you through the workout and
again sometimes like you know i do like
full body electrical muscle stimulation
workouts which sounds crazy but it's
very simple you just pull on this suit
and it stimulates your muscles while
you're exercising so you use more
muscles
it has a personal trainer that walks you
through the workout but i can download
all those workouts because they're
pre-recorded
and
um it's
it's actually
very very similar to what you might
experience in a group fitness class at a
health club or a gym so i'm not really
against that i mean i i think that
probably the two main things that we
miss out on by not being able to go to a
health club or gym or by
kind of kind of like making those
highly optional due to the emergence of
a lot of these higher end home fitness
training devices is that a
we know that
human beings thrive on connectivity to
other human beings touch eyes even the
electromagnetic signals sent out by our
hearts and our brains we are designed to
be social creatures just based on you
know that that whole idea that you know
in more ancestral times to be banished
or cut off from the village or from your
tribe usually resulted in death and we
still have kind of that that nervous
system and physiological response to
isolation that causes a lot of the
health issues that we're now seeing we
saw before covid we see it more now just
this idea that human beings don't thrive
when we are alone for long periods of
time and digital interactions do not
replace the
the what happens physiologically during
physical interactions uh and then the in
addition to missing out on that and you
know that can be replaced by dinner
partings and outings and hanging out
with friends etc but the other thing is
that there's a lot of value as well to
shared experiences
right and and honestly um that's even
more important for men than for women
you know men tend to bond over shared
experiences shared workouts shared you
know noon basketball games at the gym
shared tennis matches like that's how
guys a lot of times form friendships
that's one thing i've found is you know
when i want to make friends i'll invite
them out for frisbee golf or you know to
over to my house to do a garage workout
or something like that and you know if
you're always working out by yourself in
front of some mirror mirror on the wall
you know at your house you're also
missing out on that so i would say
if you're aware of the importance of
real human interaction and shared
experiences and you're fabricating those
somewhere else in your life then you
know working out by yourself at home
with some of these home fitness training
devices especially because of like i
mentioned the low barrier to entry that
occurs when you don't have to get in the
car drive to the gym
you know figure out what time the class
is show up shower go home you know for
me personally
if i have a chance to work out during
the day it's like a 20 or 30 minute slot
a couple times during the day and i
could use all that time driving to the
gym or i could just hop out to my garage
or my backyard or my basement throw
something down that's what i do like 90
of the time and i get all my social
interaction through you know
group dinners and and uh you know and
church outings and you know playing
tennis with folks and stuff like that so
yeah i i still think the pros outweigh
the cons of a lot of these these trendy
fitness devices for home right so since
i'm uh
in the middle of nowhere right now
disappeared throughout august my goal
basically
is in terms of working out eating that
sort of thing is i'd love to lose a
couple pounds off the belly uh tighten
up a little bit and just eat right and
feel good and you know obviously the
digital detox is the mental portion of
that
what do you tell people that are just
trying to just be like a little bit
better than they are not do like full
transformations
well
all right let let's not bore people with
the idea that you should exercise and
eat healthy right
let's assume that you've already learned
that you're supposed to you know engage
in physical activity
on a regular basis and you're supposed
to eat a diet that's you know high and
healthy
recognizable foods preferably somewhat
low in sugar and vegetable oils right
like that's that's just the basics so
far so good from there yeah yeah exactly
but then a lot of people like i'm not
seeing results i i still have low energy
levels i still have poor sleep my gut
isn't working the way that i want it to
when i try to work out i feel kind of
blah i get these food cravings that
dictate that i can't stick to that
healthy whole diet that you talk about
well
then there's the things that you know
like men's health magazine and women's
health and all these these uh um
you know modern forms of fitness media
don't tell you and really
it all comes down to viewing your body
as a battery i mean the human body
actually operates on a finely tuned
electrochemical gradient across the
membrane of every cell and if you can if
you can take that concept
and incorporate modalities into your
routine that take advantage of the fact
that you have the ability to be able to
charge up your body's battery then
you begin to see results that are
highly amplified over just you know
exercising and eating healthy so what i
mean by that is um
well i'd say this there's probably like
six things to really focus on one would
be uh light right like i'm walking out
in the sunlight right now we know that
photons of light particularly from the
sun
or even from these newfangled like
infrared light panels or infrared saunas
that are becoming very popular nowadays
these actually act to
to charge up the mitochondria they speed
up the activity of what's called the
electron transport chain they help you
to produce more atp they allow the heart
to function
more effectively you know they can lower
blood pressure increase the
effectiveness or the efficiency of the
cardiovascular system and so the regular
use of things like infrared saunas
infrared light panels and
regular sun exposure like this idea that
you should get out in the sun every
single day we know that skin cancer is
an issue with people who tan or burn or
visit the beach on the weekends and
people who like work in the sun or in
the sun regularly every day they don't
have those same issues because you
almost build up almost like this this
sun callus so right i literally live in
l.a and i've got an infrared sauna so so
far i'm doing all right yeah perfect
regular exposure to light particularly
in the morning because that's what helps
you sleep at night that's what basically
sends your body the message that its
circadian rhythm has begun in the
morning that's number one for charging
up your body number two would be
another form of charge that we have at
constant access and it's this concept of
earthing or grounding
like walking outside barefoot walking
barefoot on the beach
swimming in the ocean touching trees
touching rocks
lying you know with your shirt off in
your backyard the earth actually emits
these negative ions and
and low level frequencies that are
incredible for decreasing inflammation
for again increasing the charge
potential across those cell membranes
they're books like uh earthing or
documentaries like grounding that kind
of walk people through this and kind of
like the sun is free but there's like
those light panels or saunas we talked
about you know earthing and going
outside barefoot is free but there are
also companies now that sell like mats
that you can put underneath your top
sheet that you sleep on during the night
that plug into the grounding outlet of
your home or like in my office back in
my office i have a mat i stand on all
day long and it's just got a a little
wire and a stake planted in the ground
outside so it's as though i'm constantly
connected to the surface of the planet
sounds kind of woo but a ton of people
see huge increases in energy by not only
regular sunlight exposure but also
regular exposure to the to the surface
of the planet that's another one to
think about um
heat and cold are really popular now you
know saunas and like cryotherapy
chambers and cold plunges cold soaks
those actually do a really really good
job at also enhancing that electron flow
through the body you also get production
of things like heat shock proteins and
cold shock proteins which are fantastic
for your immune system and for cellular
resilience um you get better weight loss
especially if you like the cold in a
fasted state in the morning because you
burn a lot of fatty acids to generate
heat there's just so many benefits this
idea of regularly doing heat and cold i
mean almost every morning for me is 20
to 30 minutes in the sauna two to five
minutes in the ice or in some cold body
of water and i mean everybody who i put
on that protocol you know especially
when they're combined with like sunlight
being outside barefoot
they see huge huge improvements compared
to again just exercising or eating
healthy and then the last two things to
think about would be you know you have
to carry these charges through your body
and the way that that's done is via
water and minerals so regular intake of
really good clean pure filtered water
like i start every day and then redose
again in the afternoon with a giant 32
ounce glass of water with electrolytes
added to it i put vitamin c in there a
little bit of baking soda which is
alkaline and kind of offsets the acidity
of the vitamin c and then minerals and
so i drink that down in the morning and
then again in the afternoon and so what
i'm doing is i'm giving my body not only
the fluid that it needs to to build
blood and carry these minerals through
the body but the minerals themselves you
know we're often salt phobic these days
because of the
the impression we've been given about
the deleterious effects of salt and it
is true that salt can cause some damage
to the body you know can increase blood
pressure etc but what we're talking
about is isolated sodium chloride that
you'd find in like table salt or in
let's say like packaged foods which use
sodium chloride as a preservative but a
wide range of minerals and electrolytes
that you would get from like you know
produce grown in mineral rich soil or
these like really really good salts like
you know sea salts and rock salts and
cone of black salts and all these salts
you can add to your food and sprinkle
into your water i am a salt fiend i go
through tons of salt i go through tons
of water i do the sun and the cold every
day i'm out in the sunlight every day i
get in touch with the surface of the
planet every day and man oh man when you
combine that with
physical activity and eating a healthy
diet like those are the things that
people can do that a lot of times folks
don't think about but that's that's
where you really start moving the dial
right so let's talk about the diet stuff
so because i think a lot of people
especially in the last year and a half
they've realized that they got to take
control of their health and their lives
you know trapped at home you can't go to
the gym you're eating take out food
everything's being delivered etc etc
what's like some basic
dietary stuff that that people should
know
well
you know
the the fact is that based on
biochemical individuality you know
different shapes of the stomach the
pancreas the liver different vitamin d
excretion rates and different ways that
we all process food as unique human
beings
paired with the fact that we all have
unique genetics right like
someone from let's say sub-saharan
africa is going to do far better based
on equatorial location and sun exposure
to high carb intake and lots of fruits
and um and a lower amount of like
saturated fats compared to someone of
northern european descent who does
really good on like fish steak fermented
foods you know high fat milk stuff like
that um
you know the idea is that it's not going
to be the same for everybody
but we live in an era in which the you
know the same type of
self-quantification test that would have
cost like tens of thousands of dollars
that say like you know the princeton
longevity institute or duke or you know
any of these places where you know a lot
of execs would normally get tested to
really really dial in something like
diet or nutrition or supplementation
those are available to us in the comfort
of our own home now for you know for for
a fraction of the cost so people can
test their blood they can test their
genetics they can test their stool for
like you know what what the gut is
asking for and and
by testing your body by looking at your
genetics and by paying attention to your
own unique biochemical individuality you
should be able to tweak your diet to you
and what i mean by that is like you know
the same
ketogenic diet that your neighbor used
to lose 20 pounds might be super crappy
for you and cause inflammation and
weight gain in you because you have uh
liver and gallbladder that isn't
processing that high intake of saturated
fats very well or you have let's say
like an apple e4 e4 gene which would
dictate that high intake of fats
predisposes you to alzheimer's or
dementia or you have poor enzyme
production that dictates that you can't
burn fats that well because you don't
enough lipase and so that's just one
example of the fact that there is no one
diet that works well for everyone now
that being said
a couple of things to think about first
of all when you look at epidemiological
data for a wide wide variety of the
world's populations probably because
humans likely originated somewhere in
the fertile crescent
something along the lines of like a
ish mediterranean diet tends to work
really well for a lot of people you know
not like an olive garden unlimited
breadsticks diet but i mean like a diet
very rich in herbs and spices and you
know a wide variety of plant matter some
amounts of fish and eggs red meat but in
moderation lots of healthy omega-3 fatty
acids not only from those fish but
things like extra virgin olive oil and
avocados and avocado oil and seeds and
nuts like that low-carb mediterranean
profile tends to be something that seems
to agree with a lot of people and then
when you look at you know these blue
zones you know these longevity hot spots
around the world like you know nikoia
and acaria and sardinia and loma linda
even though the diets widely vary you
know in terms of low carb high fat um
you know high carb low fat different
plants and herbs and spices being used
in those regions different forms of
alcohol intake etc what we do see in
terms of prevailing characteristics in
all those regions is a
there's always some semblance of fasting
worked in a lot of times it's based on
on religious concepts you know like the
mediterranean diet you know it's very
popular among like eastern orthodox
christians and then there's a ton of of
special fast in that diet certain days
where you don't eat red meat certain
periods of time where you're avoiding a
high intake of proteins certain periods
of time where you're just straight up
fasting we see fasting is one
predominant characteristic of every
single healthy diet on the face of the
planet some type of fasting and some
type of time during the day or the week
or the month where you're not eating a
lot of protein
because protein in high amounts can tend
to have a little bit of an accelerated
aging effect
we also see the concept of eating with
people right um not only saying grace or
having a moment of silence or having a
moment of appreciation or sacredness
around a meal but also not stuffing your
face with a superfood smoothie while
you're you know going 65 miles an hour
down the highway on your way to work
instead and i'm highly cognizant of this
myself if i'm gonna eat i always eat in
what's called a parasympathetic state i
i sit down i do a little you know just a
few centering breasts like in through
the nose out through the mouth i say
grace i chew each bite 25 to 40 times i
try to eat with people so i'm not
distracted by my computer by my phone
but instead i'm visiting with people and
we see that
as another predominant characteristic of
a healthy diet like eating in a very low
stress state and eating with people and
then
you also see
a wide intake of a huge variety of
plants and herbs and spices and i
realize that diets like the the paleo
diet or the carnivore diet or a lot of
these highly restrictive diets have
popped up and become very popular over
the years
and a big premise of those diets is that
they eliminate a lot of
built-in plant defense mechanisms like
plants can't move and so because they
don't have hooves and teeth and claws
they develop things like you know gluten
and lectins and other things that would
cause a mammal's gut to be a little bit
disturbed cause that mammal to
poop out the seeds of that plant
elsewhere so that plant can flourish or
cause that mammal not to come back to
that plant to eat it again because it
kind of hurt
and so if you have a compromised gut or
if you have the inability to be able to
do like our ancestors would have done
and soak and sprout and ferment and
properly prepare a lot of your plant
matter then yeah doing something like a
paleo or carnivore diet has efficacy um
however in people with healthy guts who
don't have a lot of health issues like a
wide variety of plants and herbs and
spices
really seems to induce longevity and be
a healthier form of a diet and that's
another thing we see in a lot of these
blue zones they're not highly
restrictive they ate a huge variety like
100 plus different plants and herbs and
spices whereas you know in america we
often i think we're somewhere around
like 15 to 20. right so and so would you
say that paleo and carnivore that kind
of stuff like it's sort of short-term to
help fix the gut inflammation kind of
stuff but not necessarily long-term
yeah let's say you have leaky gut you
have inflammation issues you need to
kind of give your gut a break or you
need to not have a lot of gluten a lot
of lectins a lot of dairy you know
follow a carnivore diet or a paleo diet
for like 12 to 16 weeks to allow your
gut to heal and re-stabilize but then
begin to reincorporate you know things
like whatever you know kale and
cucumbers and tomatoes and you know all
those foods that you might have been
missing out on and then
probably the the final big big thing
that we see in a lot of these healthy
locations is not the absence of sugar
right we actually see a lot of these
they like their chocolates they like
their sweets um they like their candies
you look at you know the analysis of you
know centenarians or people you know
many cases who lived 115 plus years old
i was reading a fantastic article the
other day about like 20 different 115
year old people and a lot of them you
know they comment oh i love to have my
chocolate every day i love my love my
sweets and you know there's even some of
them that you know that that would like
smoke a cigarette a day and yeah but the
one thing that you'll notice in these
folks and also in a lot of these
longevity hot spots is almost complete
absence of vegetable oil intake right
canola oil safflower oil sunflower oil a
lot of these vegetable oils that we tend
to see especially in in processed and
packaged foods or used in restaurants to
cook and the reason for that is because
vegetable oils based on the fact that
they're comprised of fats are what your
body uses to create things like cell
membranes cholesterol mitochondrial
membranes your body uses these oils as
building blocks
and if they're unstable oils rancid oils
oils that have been exposed to high
amounts of heat or pressure what happens
is those vegetable oils really truly
become a case of you are what you eat
and they create rampant inflammation
weak cell membranes you know poor
metabolism and so
whereas sugar isn't as big of a deal as
most people think
vegetable oils i tell people you want to
be healthy ruthlessly eliminate
vegetable oils from your diet and
sometimes that means you're like me if i
go to a restaurant i literally ask them
like i'm that [ __ ] who says like what
what'd you cook the brussels sprouts in
or can i have my my salad but bring the
dressing on the side and then like you
know i i have like a little fanny pack i
go out with and i just have like a four
ounce thing of olive oil in there right
and i'll put olive oil in my salad
instead of whatever sauce or dressing
they have at the restaurant because i am
so aware of vegetable oil intake that's
the one you want everything everything
basically to be cooked either in olive
anything that needs to be cooked with
oil to be cooked with either olive oil
or avocado oil does it matter which one
you know
the top one the top ones i like are are
butter
ghee extra virgin olive oil avocado oil
macadamia nut oil or any super stable
animal fat like tallow or suet or any of
those fats you know coconut oil be
another one like the fats that are solid
at room temperature but not solid at
room temperature because like crisco
they've been synthesized but instead
solid because that's the way they
naturally are so so yeah so when it
comes to diet you know
just coming full circle here um you know
eat in a de-stress state have some
periods of fasting and protein
restriction be careful with sugar but
you don't got to square that off
completely completely eliminate
vegetable oil and eat a wide variety of
plants and herbs and spices and if you
can
get your genetics tested you'll get your
blood tested just kind of see what your
ancestors ate see what your bio
chemically kind of like prime to
actually be able to flourish with and
that way you can take some of those
concepts i just outlined and then tweak
your diet a little bit so it's more
customized to you how'd you get into all
this stuff were you always like this
oh no no i i i wanted to be a computer
programmer growing up i love to like
design video games and you know tear
apart my hard drive and that's really
what i wanted to do i also you know i've
dude i was homeschooled i was president
of the chess club i played violin for 13
years i you know i wrote fantasy fiction
novels like i was a total nerd growing
up but uh what got me into like
nutrition
fitness physical culture in general was
i really fell in love with tennis when i
was about 14 years old
and i just started to look into like how
you could eat healthy to be a better
tennis player and i started to you know
run the hills behind my house and you
know my dad bought me a couple of
10-pound dumbbells that i tried to learn
how to use and eventually i just got i
got so into tennis and how good fitness
and eating healthy seemed to make me
that in college i you know i studied um
you know biochemistry and biomechanics
physiology and and wound up just nerding
out on on just the entire science of the
human body and the human brain and you
know got a master's degree and all that
and i've just been immersed
immersed in that science ever since
where does uh booze fit into all of this
are you doing any wine are you doing any
tequila
any anything well speaking of speaking
of blue zones most of those folks drink
yeah and for for men it's about two to
three drinks a day for women about one
to two drinks a day
but you gotta take into account the
nature of the alcohol right we're not
talking about margarita mixes and giant
fish
martinis we're talking about like
organic biodynamic wine grown in soil
that doesn't have a lot of water added
to it so it's less irrigated so you got
a higher concentration of antioxidants
because the grapes have been beat up and
a lower concentration of sugars because
there's less water or you're looking at
like you know fermented compounds like
you know like kombucha for example
you're looking at clean burning uh
higher alcohol compounds like vodka or
gin or tequila often added to bitters
and herbs and spices so like for me
personally i do at the end of every day
either a glass of just like organic
biodynamic wine and if you don't know
you're out at a restaurant the three
countries that still do a pretty good
job at that are france italy and new
zealand it's like if you're gonna order
red out at a restaurant you're pretty
safe with those three countries and then
the other thing that that i'll do if i'm
not doing a glass of wine is a very
bitters forward mix like a poor glass of
ice a little sparkling water
put a shot of gin or vodka or tequila in
there and then just add bitters like
ginger or turmeric or lemon or lime or
even if i'm out at a uh out at a
restaurant and i'm ordering from the bar
i'll kind of glance through the cocktail
menu and choose something that's just
like a super bitters forward cocktail
and all occasionally you know if i'm
having a couple of drinks because it's a
long steakhouse dinner or something i'll
have my my glass of wine with my meal
but then leading up to that i'll just
have the uh the bartender just over the
rocks give me a selection of house
bitters with sparkling water and a
squeeze of lemon because those bitters
are actually really good for it that's
part of why alcohol can be good for you
but they also help you to digest your
food better and they even lower your
blood sugar response to a meal so
so for me it's usually like a real
bitters forward clean burning cocktail
or a glass of organic biodynamic wine
and it turns out that unless you have a
compromised liver or
um you know or you're unable to stop it
you know two or three drinks that
alcohol seems to have a little bit of a
life extending effect and it's
interesting because we see that also
with the like the plants and herbs and
spices that i mentioned with their
built-in plant defense mechanisms or
some of these centenarians who are
smoking like a cigarette a day or or the
the exposure to the radiation from
sunlight or the stress of heat or cold
like i was talking about it's kind of
like this concept of what's called
hormesis things that would be bad for
you in large amounts like alcohol which
is technically a toxin are actually good
for you in small amounts because like
exercise they beat up the body but the
body in the process of bouncing back
becomes stronger it builds more
antioxidants the cells become stronger
and so it's not an idea of living super
clean you know by living super clean you
can actually become a little bit more
weak it's about exposing your body these
mild stressors you know a perfect
example that would be you know we know
that you know back to what we were
talking about before with not going to
the gym this concept of the hygiene
hypothesis kids who grow up on farms and
around animals and with pets and who
have been exposed to lots of germs and
bacteria growing up they tend to have
stronger immune systems kids who drink
raw unpasteurized milk with all these
microbes and bacteria in it you know
which would just gross out or freak out
a lot of parents or people like they
tend to have lower incidence of asthma
and allergies because they're getting
exposed to these microbes and so that's
another perfect example of the things
that could crush you in large amounts
actually help your body to become
stronger in small amounts so so
alcohol's got a thumbs up in moderation
from the right sources right so from
alcohol where are you at with like weeds
psychedelics that kind of stuff i know a
lot of fitness people are sort of big on
weed right now even as part of the
workout routine
or regular yeah i just
i just interviewed a guy on my podcast
about this just the fascinating idea
behind the painkilling effect of like
thc and cbd especially for endurance
athletes like ultra runners or
marathoners and also for people who are
in a painful sport like fighting or
football or hockey
um
it seems like the use of cannabis either
for recovery or for pain killing as an
alternative to opioids or for being able
to just like get into the zone and push
through like low level pain like ultra
endurance running for long periods of
time it's usually beneficial for that um
cannabis also of course has has a lot of
other beneficial effects for
inflammation it's wonderful for sleep
the problem of course is to be careful
with the addictive potential of it and
also most of the research shows that in
folks who are generally about under the
age of 18 there's a deleterious impact
on mental function cognitive function uh
you know uh brain matter et cetera so be
super careful if you're young but
there's there's not a whole lot of
issues with moderated cannabis use kind
of like alcohol for adults and even
exercising adults who need it for kind
of like the pain killing or the focus
effect
and then as far as the plant medicine
piece
look like i i think there's a ton of
efficacy to microdosing
like microdosing with psilocybin or
microdosing with lsd or microdosing with
san pedro or boga or whatever not only
for workouts and exercise but for
productivity for creativity for kind of
like merging of the left and right brain
hemispheric activity that allows for you
to think in different ways than you
might have otherwise and even
neurogenesis right the growth of new
neurons which particularly happens with
uh with psilocybin
and and for some people the ego
dissolution or the personal
uh professional or spiritual
breakthroughs that can occur with larger
doses on an infrequent basis like you
know some people go to an ayahuasca
journey or others will you know use a
higher dose of psilocybin um or you know
a whole combination of different plant
medicine compounds that can also be
pretty transformative the problem is
a lot of people will use that like
as an escape
um to just kind of kind of check out you
know take a whole bunch of psilocybin
and just lose control your body and
float off into bliss for a while to
escape the pain of life that you should
be confronting head on and dealing with
in other ways or
they are um they're not doing the work
what's called the integration work
afterwards you know for me if i do a
plant medicine journey i have like four
or five days scheduled afterwards for
journaling for self-reflection for deep
work that doesn't involve the medicine
but that instead involves me just like
you know logging my thoughts and my
feelings and my breakthroughs and and a
lot of people and this is the reason why
you'll get folks doing like their 38th
ayahuasca retreat you know and they're
still the same person you talk to them
they're still searching you can see
until they're still incomplete etc it's
because
you know they're they're not doing the
work it'd be like
you know taking a taking a pre-workout
supplement
uh and and then sitting on the couch
right and not actually going to the gym
right so that's the problem is i find a
lot of people will use popping a pill
as an escape without actually wanting to
do the work and then in my opinion it
just turns into the same situation as a
drug addict you know who's just kind of
shooting up to feel good but never
actually benefits from the intended
purpose of that compound so
um so yeah for the most part there's a
lot of benefits to these to these type
of plant medicines it's just that
um i think most of the benefits are
achieved by proper use of of them via
micro dosing and then and i have a whole
section about in that in my book about
how to properly combine and stack these
you know as different microdoses for
productivity for creativity for sleep
etc and then for the larger journey
doses
i think it should be taken far more
seriously than people take it i mean the
like
for example what i mean by that is
let's say someone's going to journey
with plant medicines like deep and
actually use this as a breakthrough this
would be something you might do
during a rite of passage into adulthood
when you're 15 years old
with your
lover on your wedding night um you know
so that you can completely dissolve all
barriers and just be sitting with them
in full truth serum for you know four to
six hours on your 40th birthday and then
maybe you know as you approach your
death in life for a near-death
experience to be able to release a
little bit of the fear of death so maybe
somebody might do this like four to six
times in a lifetime right but a lot of
people now they're just like i'm
journeying bro i'm on my my second trip
to south america this year for
these are these are ayahuasca serious
things like you need to you know take
them seriously and acknowledge the
sacredness of these compounds and also
acknowledge the fact that
that that they're to be used in very
specific scenarios in a very ceremonial
setting and with a great amount of
intention and work afterwards and i just
don't see a lot of people using them in
that way yeah well listen man i uh i'm
really going to try to incorporate some
of this stuff for this month and and
then beyond so i appreciate your time
for the people that won't find you on
this little wander through the woods
where can we send them
uh
benggreenfieldfitness.com it's a pretty
good pretty good place i just wrote a
new cookbook that was my latest work
it's at boundlesscookbook.com if people
aren't trying my weird recipes i promise
there's no no psilocybin on the steak
but other than that it's all in there
and uh yeah yeah those are good places
to find me right on ben i appreciate it
awesome thanks dave thanks man if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell